[Applause]
hi drew uh
hello just just having my morning coffee
drew with you
uh you might change my sexual preference
this morning
how are you my goodness
thank you i guess thank you i'm not sure
i'm so happy to be on your show drew
congratulations i've been
a watcher since day one
i have to tell you that i have
loved you since you played vicki
in national lampoon's vacation i
am so i will never forget watching that
i mean the scene with like you know the
kissing like my daddy says i'm the best
it's just like the best
character it's so iconic it so stands
out
i'm such a big fan of yours for as long
as i can remember
thank you and we have so many mutual
friends but i don't know if we've
we've not worked together or gotten to
connect like this but we have so many
mutual friends that
i love ellie kemper was on your show
just recently and she called you human
sunshine
and i think that's the most perfect
description and now your show is
bringing your human sunshine
to all of our lives every day i am so
honored that she came on the show and
would say that and i've actually learned
a lot since that because i
wanted to tell her how much i loved her
and i kind of over talked and have like
edited myself since i'm new at this job
but i wanted to speak to her about women
in comedy
and you are one of the most important
women in comedy
how do you feel as a woman in comedy
oh my goodness i feel blessed
that i get to get amazing comedic
material that i try my hardest at and if
i can bring
a giggle a laugh or even a smile and
days like
we are going through right now it is my
pleasure and my honor
you know drew i don't know about you but
when i started doing
this business it was what i started as a
child too and it was what i always
wanted to do
and in these times it's made me so
thankful that i
get to do what i love for as many years
as i've gotten to do it
you are really good friends with tina
fey we were talking about ellie kemper
you
you know that movie and vacation when
you're a kid they're
telling you to go for it in comedy i've
i've always loved when women go for it
and i think one of my
biggest heroes is tina fey will you tell
me about your friendship with her
sure i mean she's just one of my
favorite people we had the most um
wonderful experience working on 30 rock
for seven seasons
um she's just an all-around great lady
which uh i just admire you know she
she's super smart um she's very giving
she's a wonderful boss um and
i i've stayed so close with her and i i
look to her as a guide through my
my career after having the great
pleasure of working with her for a very
long time
she's also a mom and um she's someone i
always go to for mom advice as well
when i was going through the harry
potter experience of trying to get your
child into kindergarten she was one of
the people i called up until the
deadline when my applications
and answers had to be in asking for her
opinion and which school she
she suggested because she had already
gone through the process
um and i think i continued to do that
with her um
through through our lives and i hope
that we stay friends for a very very
long time
and i've had the pleasure of working
with her on two productions i hope that
i get to do a third series with her
someday in the future
if she's game i'm sure you will because
i do find that comedy
tends to bring an alumni type of feel
and people do find their tribe and they
work together
again and again i have so much
admiration for tina fey i mean
bossypants alone
is like
i was just about to say that it's one
that i think should i just reread it
over and over because it gives me so
[Music]
much
you